fully share the sentiments expressed by
the respondent in that it is not really
this possibility of an individual or
government to chain one however a good
thing that well can change through a
collective efforts Obama administration
can help and less regard by offering the
service has really done kind of
cooperation with other countries of the
world what has done is to offer to begin
mock logistics know to carry the baggage
or the Bush administration and the
corporate with the rest of the world to
find a solution to the conflict that
filters well would you deal with the
issues that an actual cry systems also
place in the world okay I think that if
the administration become more proactive
and I failure if you be possible to
bring about positive changes in the
world I'm doing this year 2009